guy knew mark and his Porsche 356 C have
been cruising around the streets of
California for almost half a decade
during this time they've clocked up
close to a million miles together guy
has vowed to remain true to blue as he's
dubbed his constant companion
my dad gave it to me when I graduated
from college and we've been inseparable
everywhere I go I'm with blue but even
the most reliable of cars needs an
overhaul now and then as he's having
trouble starting the car and the engines
idling rough guy is headed for a repair
shop and Marina del Rey
there they meet Fred Bush the only
mechanic who's allowed to lay a hand on
blue fred is actually retired but he
gladly takes out his toolkit for one of
his most faithful customers
hey guy how are you long time no see you
know I had a problem but what's the
problem yeah let me show you the car
would not run at idle so if you have to
fix this somehow and I think one of the
people recommended that possibly the
base of the carburetors need replacing
no no probably a lot of things after a
million miles public probably the
butterfly shafts have worn out so first
we're going to inspect them if they have
to be replaced huh if it is necessary if
they do well I was at a shop with blue
since 1968 and a good friend of Fred's
worked there and so Fred left the
Porsche dealership and joined that
company and so I met him when he joined
in 1971 I guess that's a few years ago
that's like 45 years ago or so and
that's where we made the relationship
and blue has been our bond I mean
whatever we do we do together with blue
so we've had a great time and blue keeps
running so that's what's important
Fred was born in Germany and learned his
craft working at a VW and Porsche
dealership on Berlin's famous
Kurfurstendamm Boulevard so he's an
expert on old Porsches and has repaired
blue many a time
Bahama Fred says they've installed a new
crankshaft and a new camshaft they put
in new pistons and cylinders he reckons
one cylinder head or maybe both have
been replaced in the past but the body
is in original condition
omocha knox with funk although he's 70
years old Fred still likes to tinker
with cars so in addition to taking care
of the rough idling he also tightens the
fan belt this thread says it feels good
to remember the things you learned way
back in life and he still enjoys
performing his work now it's still a lot
of fun this notion these are bite yet
Stewart's affion that's my bass
the reason blue has been able to rack up
almost a million miles is mainly thanks
to Fred fred is a success he's the
reason because blue is a mechanical item
Porsche builds a wonderful wonderful car
as we see every time we close a door or
we do anything in the car it's tight
it's fit it's right but you still have
to help someone maintain the car and
that's a key I would visit Fred every
3,000 miles and Fred was there to take
care of it and you'd say oh guy look at
these these lines need to be replaced so
he was always a step ahead and so boo
kept running and running fred has
replaced most of the wearing parts the
Porsche 356 C has barely needed any
major repairs blues engine and
transmission have proven remarkably
reliable at eight hundred and eighty-one
thousand miles
finally the crank said okay time for a
new one and we said great but at that
point amazingly enough we had never been
in the transmission and nothing had ever
been done to the transmission and then
we heard some noises we said okay let's
go in and take a look we replaced five
bearings and blew now it's running like
a dream so with the engine work we've
just done in the transmission we're
ready for another million the Porsche
still has some 5,000 miles to go to hit
the million mark when it reaches that
milestone guy plans to celebrate with
friends and glue of course
you